alors que depuis le 4 janvier dernier
marie sophie lacarrau a repris le
journal de 13h de tf1 en remplacement de
jean-pierre pernaut voilà que la
première polémique vient d'éclater
bon courage pour la suite merci jean
cartes étaient du côté de france 2 où
elle anime également le journal de 13
heures que les choses semblent
s'envenimer
selon les informations du journal le
parisien le jour de l'annoncé de son
départ pour tf1 au directeur de
l'information de france télévisions
marie sophie lacarrau aurait demandé à
la direction des ressources humaines du
groupe de bénéficier du plan de départs
volontaires et donc de toucher un petit
pactole de cent soixante mille euros
pour ses 20 ans passés à france
télévisions un cadeau printemps que de
noël une demande déplacer pour la
présidente du groupe delphine ernotte
qui aurait décidé de suspendre
immédiatement de l'antenne la
journaliste toujours bon de le rappeler
marie sophie lacarrau suite à cet
agacement de la part de la direction
aurait finalement renoncé à demander une
indemnité de départ une version que la
journaliste conteste aujourd'hui
assurant que tout cela est faux alors
départ de france 2 croyez-vous
révélations sur les demandes
d'indemnités de marie sophie lacarrau
nicolas pernikoff qui a enquêté
qu'est ce que c'est que ça t'a fait
alors spectateurs ça ça les intérieurs
pris il ya un plan de rupture
conventionnelle collectif c'est vrai
dire que tout collaborateur qui est en
cdi sur france télévisions peut s'il a
un job derrière peut demander une
indemnité de départ et faire partie de
ce plan collectif donc ce que je pense
moi c'est qu'elle a posé sa démission et
comme tout salarié
elle a demandé si elle pouvait faire
partie de ce plan ce qui ne me choque
pas puisque c'est un droit et c'est un
dû il ya deux mille salariés qui
auraient pu en profiter ça un plomb
jusqu'à 2022
je crois qu'il a fait sur les absences
alors il les aurait prise entre les
indemnités non dans les apprenants les
amap risque d'accord c'est très bien la
redon si elle a renoncé voilà est-ce que
c'est pas un peu remué je le dis remue
la merde ça c'est quelqu'un qui vient de
démarrer sur tf1 franchement elle a
l'air hyper sympa moi je vais vous dire
je vais envoyer de sms
à chaque fois elle m'a répondu très
gentiment elle se prend pas la tête à la
pala dans le steak talent et sa voix à
kirill ce nom mais on cherche toujours
la petite bête hein je trouve que c'est
insupportable moi j'ai eu la vie elle
vient d'arriver elle est géniale elle
cartonne
donc là comme on peut pas l'attaquer sur
ces audiences ont essayé de trouver un
truc pour l'attaqué elle l'a fait encore
42 % de parts de marché hier marie
sophie lacarrau elle fait un carton sur
tf1
ça y est pour elle je vous dis c'est
parti pour pour 30 ans et
encore des mecs qui viennent chercher la
petite bête je vous dire à force de
chercher la petite bête comme ça chez
tout le monde mais c'est vrai il ya des
mecs qui créé des milliers d'emplois
non mais c'est vrai et on va leur
chercher aussi la petite bête continue à
avoir ces mecs là qui vont qui vont et
qui vont plus pouvoir embaucher par
exemple leur arrêt aux stands mais c'est
insupportable marie sophie lacarrau elle
vient d'arriver la peau elle a rien fait
elle a jamais fait chier personne et là
on lui saute dessus on y trouve des
histoires je suis trouve ça un petit peu
limite voilà je vous dis franchement non
mais pour l'avoir vécu à france
télévisions tout le monde est passé par
france télé ont tous les animateurs sont
passés france télévisions oui souvent on
reproche à france télévisions ne pas
être audacieux pas prendre des risques
qu'ils prennent des risques nation
audacieux mais à un moment donné moi je
sais pas quand c'est exactement un
moment donné où est passé l'argent et
faire leurs courses mais la manière de
manière dont elle est partie lyon est un
petit peu brutale et rapide
donc ils ont pu aussi mal le vivre il
faut l'accélérer les nations ça va vous
sinon vous aimez ce but qui nous coupe
ah j'adore j'adore mon boulot c'est là
mais c'est comme ça la plupart ouverte
on ne voit plus rien sans mes lunettes
d'accord vous inquiétez pas je vous
trouve magnifique mon nom j'ai vu ça
j'ai un petit peu enquêter ils sont des
choses vous m ont eu lieu dans la je
vous adore à l'émotion géant kenya ont
pris beaucoup de gens qui sont le lieu
où cela 40 mois à france télé et j'ai
hâte que que que élise lucet fasse un
cachot investigations sur les méthodes
de france 2 sur ces licenciements
il ya beaucoup de gens qui avons soumis
dans des postes qui ne sont pas des
leurs qui seront mis au placard et ses
entraînements ne pas s'essayer vous
explique il ya une politique de
licenciement aujourd'hui à france
télévisions qui est un petit peu un
petit peu tendu et un petit peu dur et
effectivement c'est pour ces jeux mais
plutôt que d'embêter sophie lacarrau ce
projet sur le marie-sophie sélingué
alors non juste et chérie moi moi le
fournil pour ratifier nature sur ce que
je viens de dire il s'appelle scott est
d'accord avec moi ma chérie bien sûr
c'est incroyable qu'on ait toujours
chercher la petite bête elle vient
d'arriver
elle elle est heureuse on vient lui
casser la tête j'ai entièrement d'accord
et thomas sotto à noter que vous l'aviez
cité pour le 13h ils adorent thomas et
moi je peux des skis
oui bonsoir oui au sexe ce qui est sûr
c'est que ce qui est sûr c'est que ce
fils à carouge soient partis à la
concurrence dr jocelyn d'une petite
phrase du patron de l'info de france
télévisions avant ses débuts où il avait
dit marie sophie n'est pas jean pierre
pernaut j'avais trouvé ça pas très sympa
non l'encourager fait laurent le minier
préfère pas ouais mais on sait qu'il ya
des petites tensions en tout cas entre
eux et une autre info qui dans cet
article justement dont on a parlé
séquelles gagné 110 mille euros par an à
france télé on s'est beaucoup moins que
ce qu'elle va être payé c'est beaucoup
moins que ce qu'elle est payée à tf1 et
jade rien moi moi moi je voudrais dire
encore en autrefois quatre chapeaux à
thierry thuillier le patron de l'info
tf1 parce que je vous le dis il y en a
pas un qui était d'accord avec lui sur
le choix de marie sophie lacarrau en
scène balle à quand on voit les scores
qu'elle fait elle a 42 % les jours il
nous a tous fermer notre gueule
oui c'est vrai oui mais moi j'ai entendu
tout le monde parlait nicolas pas
particulièrement et bazin et ça vous
choque pas vous que quand on démissionne
on vous donne 160000 euros d'un des
matches ici ça ne pouvait démissionner
on n'a pas regardé l'occitane a fait une
émission dans toutes les sociétés où tu
démissionnes passion tu vas aller chez
la concurrence jamais tu peux rentrer
dans un bureau d'un mec pour dire toc
tassili tu peux 160000 euros avec
l'argent du compte et si c'est moi pour
moi je vais te dire pour moi 11 à 10
j'ai vu ça dans le parisien alors la
saluons la salle j'ai toujours ce que je
pense mari est seul à carreaux sophie
lacarrau on l'a saly où elle est rentrée
dans le bureau d'yves 260 milles pour
prendre 160000 en se disant bassong je
vais prendre beaucoup d'argent chez tf1
mais je vais encore manger avec les
160000 de francs la somme on l'a sa vie
ou alors c'est le parisien qui ment mais
où c'est france 2 qui ment ou c'est le
parisien qui ment en attendant elle est
au milieu
et pour moi les salles et les sanitaires
a frappé dans un bureau pour demander
160000 quand tu sais que ça nous amène
djellaba demandé et que tu va le prendre
200 milles sur tf1 l'année
l'annoncé large en france elle est allée
salies oui ses amis et on est d'accord
que l'afrique du sud était pour la
déstabiliser mais vous jeter de l'eau
nicolas n'avait pas parlé à la famille
ali en tout cas elles sont maintenant
elle s'en prend plein la tête sur les
réseaux sociaux à cause de ça où on dit
qu'à prend l'argent des français alors
que non mais je trouve qu'elle a été je
trouve qu'elle a été honnête et sens
éthique je peux comprendre que ça puisse
choquer au sens juridique elle avait le
droit
elle a renoncé quand elle a vu le teint
3 pas possible que ça faisait au sam 21
points et les visions et surtout elle
aurait très bien pu dire au printemps
attendent et ne pas dire je vais sur tf1
donnez moi mes indemnités puisque j'y ai
droit jeudi elle a été en défaut c'était
trop vite les gens peuvent acheter vous
poser des vraies surprises mais est-ce
qu'il faut poser question qu'est-ce
qu'elle a été salie l'ex de rihanna et
estonie à l'acte est salie alors elle a
été servie mais j'en croise d'ailleurs
salimata qui me regardent peut-être
qu'ils avaient de gros bisous oui non
mais effectivement qu'on lui cherche la
petite bête c'est normal puisque elle
cartonne
donc ça va très bien ils ont tenu à la
télévision on essaye de le devenir est
d'aller gratter dans mille ya un truc
était assez amusant et quand elle a pris
en fait le rôle de la place de
jean-pierre pernaut une des premières
interviews qu'elle est faite elle a été
en fait quand tf1 m'a appelé pour
présenter le journal de 13 heures j'ai
absolument pas demandé combien j'allais
gagner
je m'en foutais puisque l'important
c'était de passer à l'antenne et de
prendre ce poste était un poste
honorifique
elle a été un petit peu ça l'a été sa
malice et certains modèles qui va bien
peut-être quelque chose d'intéressant
après c'est pas sur ses passions alors
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi ne va
falloir une croix bon sens mais je suis
le très beau je vous dis oui j'ai pris
en exemple here c'est vrai ouais où ça
le nom auprès de très beaux pour son âge
merci servi à line renaud si ces jours
ci alors alors donc ce que je voulais
dire c'est pourquoi ne va-t-on pas
croire cette femme
elles démentent cette histoire il faut
la croire c'est une femme formidable
mais j'ai une femme bien alors j'ai
enquêté figurez-vous moi aussi j'ai
appelé deux personnes justes et skate
suite dans ce nom alors j'ai appelé la
présidence avec france télévisions s'en
faisant 5 me canis 80000 euros par an
j'ai appelé la présidente de france
télévisions modèle delphine ernotte
elle vous a répondu oui voilà pas voulu
me dire la vérité et finnair note vous a
répondu oui là à l'instant c'était moi
balmine où elle vient de m'appeler très
sympa mais pour l'embrasser mais plutôt
pour
nous allons donc déjeuner prochainement
je l'espère d'accord et elle n'a pas
voulu répondre c'est là bien sûr j'ai
appelé laurent guimier qui ne m'a pas
répondu non plus qu'il ait dit oui
non c'est pas vrai ce que tu dis raymond
elle est dans son bon droit à marie
sophie lacarrau comptable en entreprise
que tu démissionnes où tu fais une
rupture conventionnelle tu touches de la
rassurer et échanger avec des mois de
salaire 5000 euros quant à 20 ans
d'entreprise et que tu gagnes 110000
euros par an ce qui est évidemment un
énorme salaire c'est pas des commandes
ou qu'elle était dans son bon droit
effectivement c'était mal vu parce
qu'elle partait à la concurrence et
qu'elles aient gagné trois ou quatre
fois plus tu es là dit non donc
franchement là rien n'a fonctionné ce
qu'en pensent les téléspectateurs oui à
49%
croyez-vous à des révélations des
demandes oui à 42 me semble non à 51%
oui mais je dis donc quoi qu'il arrive
je trouve pas chez de corps et crée mon
ciel était tranquille il l'on saluera